here's the back of the door the front
door is the trick bus with the strippers
booty so when the booty years old and
I'm standing there well this is not
happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. now tonight's
episode it's not for the faint of heart
in fact you might even want to cover
your ears because tonight
[Music]
you don't man from his work on The Daily
Show but rather the
promised if nothing else is the
opportunity for you to experience other
cultures I grew up in Birmingham Alabama
Birmingham and the 90s was very
black-and-white there wasn't a lot of
diversity in the city so when I went to
college in Tallahassee this was my first
time experience in all these different
cultures and foods and people and music
was the one thing that I really got my
nose open to man cuz I thought it was
just you know southern rap I thought it
was just Outkast and you know a little
bit of NWA and you know and I got to
college and my roommate cooter my
homeboy he put me on the routine movie
music exposed to while I was in college
was Miami Bass Miami Bass music was
amazing hands down Luther Campbell of 2
Live Crew is the most important rapper
in the history of the genre I'll double
down on that Luther Campbell of 2 Live
Crew the most important musician of the
last 30 years period last 30 years
Luther Campbell 2 Live Crew all they did
was make songs about 6 song titles like
pop that coochie me so horny
throw the dick doodoo brown I don't know
what
you could always hear a girl in the
background of every Miami but you could
hear it in the base oh my god the base
the base of this music man this is this
is what originated white people this is
the stuff that was shaking your car for
a cutlass the pass by Miami bass
rattle in the truck Luther Campbell's
music was so obscene that record store
owners were arrested for selling it
that's how crazy it was back in the day
so Luther Campbell decided to be a
little you know I got an idea to keep
these shop owners from getting in
trouble I'm gonna label my albums so
that people know that it's vulgar he
created what we know today as the
parental advisory sticker he created
that nobody else they still arrested him
for obscenity for performing hit songs
such as throw that dick and pop that
coochie
but he was the only one that was getting
arrested that had the guts to take the
government head-on man this dude took
the government head-on and won he won
and because of that any performer that
you can name right now the only reason
you can buy their like a regular
American is because Luther
Campbell fought for the First Amendment
to be able to say whatever the hell he
wanted to say get a van I don't even
know how to describe this but he was a
pioneer of promotion as well and any any
rap group that you see now that has a
van with all of the logos wrapped in all
the design Luther Campbell did it first
and they had a freak van it's called
Luke's freak van and the 2 Live Crew van
you'd be outside a nightclub at 2
o'clock in the morning and you can hear
this van coming from around the corner
you go outside and you see this van
turning the corner and then have the
neon lights on the bottom partitions
there were plexiglass partitions in the
back part of the van and there is a van
cruising by did what any would have done
I chased this van
all the way up West Tennessee Street I'm
running alongside the loop freak van
trying to get a glimpse that's what Luke
dancers were about man Luke dancers they
would like to SEAL Team six description
I don't know how to how else to describe
him but it was just amazing stuff and
that was that was there was a lot of my
my teenage years in college was going to
Luke shows and just watching all of this
debauchery unfold on stage so imagine my
delight a couple years later I'm
interning at a radio station and my boss
comes up because hey yeah I'm having a
bachelor party if you want to know cover
his bachelor party it's gonna be Luke
dances the grinch like smile when I
found out I had an opportunity to be in
the same building as the Luke dancers so
I go to this why not go to this party I
earn clothes iron and out said I was
gonna impress the Luke dance and put a
crease in my khakis how are you doing so
I go to his bachelor party and I'm
sitting in the corner and I don't know
if you ever been to a bachelor party
before the strippers get there but it's
very awkward very awkward it's twenty
thirty man just all sitting there and
they just
[Music]
the residential neighborhood all the
graphics and stuff planted yeah to Live
Crew on the front you had women like
this but the door the front door of the
freak bus was the strippers booty so
when the door
what happens over the next two hours in
the house come out in the room and oh my
god man they take an alcohol and pour
alcohol and a lightning and his flaming
titties dancing with flaming nipples
yeah remember this is 1997 this is still
dial-up porn so I've never seen any of
this only women is like playboy and so I
have to play outside so I'm just
observing it's where we're in the midst
of something that can be flaming titties
like just over them there's a man and I
can't really make him out from that
distance but there's a man and he's
sitting there and he's reading a Wall
Street Journal
we smokin cigarettes how are you reading
this Wall Street drew so i inch closer
to this man can i get a little closer
and i can make him out now
it's a Luther Campbell I'm trying to
figure out what to say to this guy what
to say to this man it's done so much for
me at this point cuz this is the same
man who went all the way to the Supreme
Court and he won he legitimately changed
the face of not only music but comedy
you see that from across the room and
it's easy it's very easy to put people
in one box you know but it's not fair
cuz we can be many things is Luther
Campbell a man that built his career on
some music that a lot of people were
considered disrespectful and
misogynistic to women it slowly could
make that argument but you can also make
the argument that he was one of the most
important legal trailblazers and
entertainment in the last three decades
you can beat both things and I'm trying
to figure out how to put that into the
shortest sentence possible because I
don't want to interrupt this man and now
I really want to get back to the flaming
titties
and I creep over to this man and I'm
trying to figure out what to say and
before I could open my mouth Luther
Campbell lowers his Wall Street Journal
looks me dead in the eyes and goes you
welcome
[Applause]